[Musique]
il ya tellement de choses qu'on peut pas
des prêtres des plombes et trucs 5
c'est simple puis c'est surtout très
gratifiante se rendre compte qu'on peut
réduire le gaspillage alimentaire on
peut réduire nos déchets à la maison
sans que ce soit compliqué puis que ce
soit la chose auquel on pense toute la
journée en préparant aux légumes et aux
fruits pour un repas on a le réflexe de
pelé paris et jeté au compostage ce que
l'on considère comme des déchets ici on
se trompait
bach gaspillage alimentaire pour moi
c'est une des suites en fait logique de
comment on peut avoir des habitudes qui
ont réduit en fait notre impact
environnemental en tant qu'individu en
tant que famille j'ai l'impression de
jeter l'argent directement dans le
compost quand je gaspille 1 1 à milan on
le voit avec la hausse du coût de la vie
est actuellement basse assure qu'on va
faire beaucoup plus attention à la
manière dont on achète on fait notre
épicerie c'est ça si on peut cuisiner
plus de choses faire plus de repas
partir d'un aliment mais pourquoi pas on
dirait que c'est pas parfait mais c'est
pas mon premier pelage
guillaume cantin dirige la
transformerait un organisme à but non
lucratif qui donne une seconde chance
aux aliments mal aimé
chose qu'il faut pas oublier des fois
c'est qu'on n'a même pas besoin pelé le
fruit ou légume on peut l'utiliser en ci
malgré ce sont le père on a déjà la
place et sur le défaut d être d'emblée
on va penser à faire un bouillon avec
des poids lourds de légumes sommeil
tellement les choses qu'on peut faire
avec des plots dépendent autant on peut
faire des gens de cheap avec des pleurs
de carottes on peut faire des
croustilles et sucrés mais c'est des
choses qui sont cinq qu'on peut faire
rater n'ont pas besoin d'avoir de
grandes compétences c'est juste on le
fait avec les plans fiscaliste de façon
simple et rapide sur une plaque de
cuisson on dépose les murs de carottes
puis on ajoute du sucre en poudre a fait
d'enlever un peu d'amertume on enfourne
à 3 125 degrés pendant environ 10
minutes sans faire des courses cik vont
être légèrement script que les enfants
vont raffoler mais aussi les adultes et
j'entre qu'on sort du four puis qu'une
fois qu'on s'est sorti ça d'une façon
nous auraient une vie très longue c'est
vraiment fun
coûte tout goûter ouais c'est fait par
un chef
si ça peut être intéressant de matisse
un gâteau qui a récupéré le servir vous
avez utilisé par laurent grand tokyo ce
que je remarque c'est que ça a été fait
par un maître peu leur aussi
mais qu'en est il des résidus de
pesticides qui peuvent se trouver sur
les fruits et légumes si on n'achète pas
bio je l'avais fruits et légumes tout
simplement à l'eau éventuellement dès
qu'on peut y ajouter un peu de
bicarbonate de soude ça peut aider aussi
à nettoyer pour la surface après il faut
être conscient qu'on sait que maintenant
on a des semences qui sont traités aux
pesticides aussi fait qu' il peut y en
avoir comme ça une diète avec des fruits
et légumes est supérieur en termes de
bienfaits que d'éviter les frais légumes
parce qu'on craint ni pesticides
d'autant plus que les peuls sûrs
feuilles et tiges recèle une bonne
quantité de vitamines minéraux et fibres
qui c'est le cas des pelures de pommes
de terre auquel guillaume ajoute d'abord
un peu d'huile on met un peu de serre
juste pour asean et puis on vient bras
c'est juste pour bien les enduire de
l'huile on a un faux qui est préchauffé
à 350 degrés fahrenheit fait tout ce
qu'il reste à faire c'est vraiment les
déposer à plat comme ça
les feuilles de choux fleurs sont tout à
fait délicieuse grillé également avec de
l'huile
on va rajouter du sel mais on pourrait
mettre des épices qui a ri madoff par
exemple c'est parce que j'aime dire aux
gens aussi ça peut être aux épices qui
traînent autour des épices qui
travaillent les faucons acheté pour une
recette on sait plus quoi faire avec
parce qu'on a fait pour la recette mais
pourquoi pas les utiliser la rue pendant
que les feux cuisent on prépare les
choeurs de chou fleur en crudités comme
on fait avec les choeurs de brocoli 6e
pas savoureux pierre nettement c'est
vraiment entendre les crudités que
j'aime le plus le fait que cage fait ce
je vais juste me faire des petits bords
tanins qui après si on peut mettre les
épices qu'on veut mais moi j'aime bien
ça je suis un manger une duxelle un prêt
lecteurs de brocolis les terres de
chou-fleur
un code secret quand ce juteux tag auto
souffleur avec un petit délicieux moment
merci fini le gaspillage des coeurs
[Musique]
j'ai qu à peu près sept minutes après
j'ai retourné la plaque de 180 degrés et
j'ai fait trois minutes de plus fait kim
soo voix il y en a cassé vraiment
colorés comme ça c'est super
croustillant les feuilles de choux gras
rôti bien sûr ses meilleurs shows et
quand ça sort du four là on est cuits
soit les plus petites feuilles une
vingtaine de minutes défaut les grosses
feuilles 25-30 minutes ça goûte vraiment
le chou chou fleur un peu entre les deux
le bus et dqm avoir encore un peu de
textures sur la tige que ça soit
croquant une belle coloration sur les
feuilles seul devant plus de raison de
mettre au compost ont vraiment ce
suspense est bon en plus fait qu'avec
les trucs qu'on a partagé autant la
feuille on petit les feuilles le cas il
n'y a plus rien qui se passe maintenant
que ce soit des fanes de carottes des
feuilles de radis de betterave ou de
celle vit pratiquement tout peut changer
même les tiges de care émincés et gris à
la poêle il suffit d'un peu
d'imagination
je veux dire tiens en toute fin rippy tu
me soit par dessus un tradition encore
de cette femme dans ses bras vraiment un
très bon goût on pense à tout les types
de légumes pratiquement c'est le même
principe les tiges de betteraves de
bette à carde toutes ces tiges l'on peut
lier travail et la main de maicon de
façon très simple on récupère les fanes
de carottes
on peut les hacher commune hermes après
ce litige d'herbe le persil italie au
persil plat la coriandre ici ben si gela
au final sont les nettoie et bien ben
moi je suis là je trouve ça plus
savoureux même que les feuilles pas en
plus ça donne la texture section les
prend on pense que ces exemples la
ciboulette panier les maçons l'état et
finement vont plaire ajouter encore là
dans des plats comme une herbe tout
simplement c'est super amoureux
en terminant nous avons tenté une
expérience avec guillon on a vu passer
une recette dans les internets de bacon
de bananes donc le principe c'est quoi
le principe c'est pas une genre de
marinade ces composés principalement de
sauce soya de sirop d'érable dos
il ya des épices aussi bien sûr du pack
office mais aussi la fumée liquide pour
die de la peau de redonnions fait que
c'est pas mal les ingrédients qui
composent cette recette là nous disent
amassé 15 minutes ont fait griller à feu
moyen en vérifiant souvent l'état de la
cuisson parce que déjà visuellement ça
ressemble à du véhicule oui la question
c'est est-ce que ça va goûter le bic
[Musique]
phone mais saragosse 0 le becquet et
carmen le goût de banane qui régnèrent
l'arrière ça goûte la fumée c'est quand
même bon honnêtement parce que robin et
quand une amertume là dedans et on le
sent pas moi c'est pas mal non c'est pas
mal plus le plus juteux
mais est-ce que je prendrais c'est que
les hull la taxation de la question
merci pour cette proposition
une